le double homicide et à masnières villes
affectées d'autant plus les
fonctionnaires de police et déjà touchés
par l'état d'urgence les attentats de
paris en novembre dernier également par
les violences à leur encontre lors des
dernières manifestations contre le
projet de loi travail
c'est ce que confie loïc travers
secrétaire national adjoint du syndicat
police alliance nationale
il a témoigné au nom au nom du syndicat
son écoeurement et son abattement face à
ce drame il apporte tout son soutien aux
fonctionnaires de police des mureaux
également de mantes-la-jolie nous
l'avons eu en interview par téléphone
aujourd'hui écoutés je crois qu'à
travers ce double attaque l'ina ce sont
toutes les institutions de la république
toute la police nationale qui est
endeuillée touchés et on peut clairement
dire aujourd'hui que rien ne sera plus
comme avant à policier agressé à son
domicile
c est un pas nouveau notamment dans le
cadre d'un acte de terrorisme et le
sentiment de tranquillité ou de répit
que les policiers se doit d'avoir
et bien voilà après qu'ils ont effectué
leur dur labeur de deux journées eh bien
elle n'est plus et là il ya quelque
chose de très choquant sur le fait que
c'est bien compliqué d'assurer sa propre
défense et surtout celle de sa famille
et ce soir à différents syndicats de
police ont reçu par le ministère de
l'intérieur afin que les fonctionnaires
de police soient tarn et en tout lieu et
en tout temps c'est leur demande ce sera
une décision qui serait prise sur la
base du volontariat les syndicats
demandent qu'elle soit effective
même en dehors de l'état d'urgence